et on va plus loin avec un dam
mustafavid directrice adjointe de la
rédaction de L'Express l'hebdomadaire
inquiétite sur la face cachée du
bien-être cette semaine vous n'avez
d'ailleurs apporté on va le voir
normalement
à l'écran la face cachée du bien-être
alors voilà il est tout y passe un yoga
nature
on essaie de démêler le vrai du faux
dans toutes ces pseudos
face à vous Gautier ribinsky chroniqueur
international à France 24 bonsoir
l'homéopathie non non pour ouvrir le
débat une face cachée elle aura en tout
cas elle dirigeait le Royaume-Uni sous
deux monarques et puis c'est à peu près
tout nommé à la tête du gouvernement à
la fin de l'été leur a quitté avant même
les premiers frimades l'automne 45 jours
c'est le record de brièveté qui aura
duré le passage de listrus à d'un
instruite le temps de dévoiler un
programme manifestement pas du goût des
investisseurs qui étaient pourtant
censés en être les premiers
bénéficiaires puis finalement donc de
remballer ce programme écoutez là
aujourd'hui à l'heure où elle annonce
son départ justifiée en quelques mots
cette émission
je suis entré en fonction en détent de
grands instabilité économique et
internationale
Kevin étant donné cette situation je ne
peux pas appliquer le programme sur
lequel j'ai été élu par le Parti
conservateur
j'ai donc parlé à Sa Majesté le Roi pour
lui notifier le fait que je démissionne
comme chef du Parti conservateur
ça vous a surpris malgré toi madame même
si on savait dans une situation
inconfortable il stress c'est difficile
de dire que c'est pas surprenant parce
que c'est vraiment très court comme
temps de mandat mais c'était tellement
attendu que voilà il y avait une blague
qui surprisait sur les réseaux sociaux
où il y avait Downing string avec une
porte mine d'or
ministre Royaume-Uni c'est vraiment
rentré et sortir et c'est vrai qu'on dit
44 jours mais dans les faits entre la
mort de la reine qui est survenue deux
jours après le début de son mandat puis
les funérailles qui ont du enfin voilà
le deuil national qui a duré 15 jours
[Musique]
d'abord les marchés sont vraiment
ingrats trouvaient pas ils sont
cette dame fait tout pour se conformer à
la doxa des marchés et au fond elle est
abandonnée au milieu du gué alors certes
parce que elle n'avait pas fait de
financement précis de ces baisses
d'impôts enfin quand même elle avait
garanti la chose pour les plus aisés des
citoyens britanniques et les marchés la
lâche c'est vraiment moche et donc ce
qui s'est passé là oui pour répondre à
votre question il y a une remise en
cause bien sûr de ce de ce dogme en ce
sens où elle arrive avec cette idée très
précise et elle connaît la situation
dans laquelle le Royaume-Uni se trouve
non seulement bien sûr à cause de la
guerre en Ukraine mais structurellement
chaque par exemple nouveau Premier
ministre nouvelle Première ministre par
du système de santé il y a quantité de
dépenses à faire et que se passe-t-il
elle elle arrive arc-bouter sur cette
anachronisme qui est au fond maintenant
devenu une Margaret Thatcher en disant
je vais faire comme elle et forcément
même les mêmes les le conservateur
disent non ça ne peut pas marcher on est
en plus à une inflation on l'a vu on a
vu ceux qui ont fait grève aussi juste
le lendemain je crois de de
l'enterrement de de la Reine Elisabeth
donc il y a des tensions énormes dans
cette société et vous avez quelqu'un qui
arrive avec finalement un dogme tel
qu'il était il y a 15-20 ans et le
problème on en reparlera peut-être tout
à l'heure c'est qu'au fond il t'a doublé
par une partie même de son propre parti
et donc ça veut dire que si vous voulez
c'est une frange relativement peu
importante du Parti conservateur des
terroristes qui a propulsé l'histoire au
poste de première ministre on ne peut
plus comme Margaret Thatcher ou Ronald
Reagan en leur temps imposer une
révolution des idées et aujourd'hui
faire du Royaume-Uni parce que c'était
visiblement l'intention affichée par
l'histoire un paradis fiscal une
Singapour sur la Tamise au mépris des
équilibres budgétaires c'est ça
l'enseignement l'enseignement c'est que
au bout d'un moment le
mensonge global dans lequel conservateur
depuis six ans depuis faut quand même se
rappeler que le brexit c'était à la base
le référendum sur le brexit c'était à la
base pour résoudre les tensions internes
aux parties conservateurs donc là on est
6 ans plus tard et finalement oui ça
peut pas fonctionner parce que tout ça
c'est bâti sur une idée une le brexit
l'idée même du brexit et bâti sur cette
dérégulation sur cette idée que le
Royaume-Uni est tout seul dans son île
et qu'il y a pas d'Europe il y a pas de
de marché mondiaux mais ce n'est pas on
a bien vu que c'est pas vrai et donc au
bout d'un moment les conservateurs ils
se retrouvent coincé dans leur propre
tissus de mensonges ils ont entouré bon
après ça veut pas dire que les travails
seraient forcément meilleurs c'est il
s'agit pas de d'un parti mais en tout
cas là c'est vrai qu'il ça a montré les
limites de ce qu'on peut dire sans
aucune le contre modèle en tout cas
l'Union européenne est mort son ministre
son chancelier d'expliquer qu'elle a
quand même viré alors que c'était son
meilleur ami kwazy cartel la semaine la
dernière on les appelait quand même
Batman et Robin donc ils sont
extrêmement proches donc à partir du
moment où elle le désavoue c'est quand
même elle est dans une grande difficulté
ce ministre il n'avait pas forcément
calculé ça par rapport à la réalité de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
Royaume-Uni donc il y a une limite à
faire des plans sur la comète sans
aucune prise avec la réalité le Parti
conservateur annonce la désignation d'un
ou d'une successeur d'ici la fin de la
semaine prochaine avant vendredi 28
octobre les conservateurs peuvent-ils
néanmoins Gautier faire l'économie d'un
retour devant les électeurs non
non mais ça va être probablement une des
culottées faramineuse pour les
conservateurs mais c'est vrai que ce que
disait ce sont ils se sont autoproclamés
nombril du Royaume-Uni depuis des années
et au fond ça n'a que très peu d'intérêt
je vous disais tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait une frange des conservateurs qui
avait propulsé l'histoire parce que
justement on était dans ce fantasme dans
cette idéologie des bienfaits de la
dérégulation à tout prix indépendamment
de la réalité bon le brexit c'était ça
aussi c'est une aventure avant tout
presque enfin imaginaire au sens que on
aspire à quelque chose de merveilleux et
qu'on en décrit les contours sauf qu'on
n'a pas le matériau pour fabriquer cette
affaire donc il y a ça et les
conservateurs bien sûr ne peuvent pas
faire l'économie d'autant qu'en plus si
vous voulez avec ce vous allez dire ce
marigot des conservateurs on est dans la
position où c'est justement une petite
fraction ou une autre qui va dégager des
voix pour un candidat ou une candidate
laquelle se trouvera se retrouvera donc
première min au Premier ministre de
l'ensemble d'un pays ce qui est
fascinant c'est que face à elle il faut
rappeler qu'il y avait Richy sunac qui
est aussi un conservateur donc puisque
le vote s'est fait au sein du Parti
conservateur puisqu'on Royaume-Uni c'est
le chef du parti fin du parti qui a
remporté les élections qui finalement
c'est pas non plus un enfant de cœur
mais il avait l'air tellement posé face
à elle parce que plusieurs orthodoxes
parce que tout simplement il était il
prenait une certaine prudence économique
et il dit il a dit dès le départ que
c'était un conte de fée ce que proposait
l'histoire
donné raison il est possible
psychologique bénéficiaires de à mon
avis je suis je pense que même s'il
devrait retourner de devant les urnes le
Parti conservateur est tellement c'est
le sens voilà ma question finalement
pour clore ce chapitre est-ce que les
travailistes qui ont joué sont des
traînette mentait dans les sondages
kerstarmer leur chef réclame à corps et
à créer une élections est-ce qu'ils ont
les moyens de contraindre les
conservateurs un retour aux ur alors
constitutionnellement ils n'ont pas de
ils n'ont aucun moyen de contraindre les
conservateurs il n'y a que l'opinion
publique mais bon l'opinion publique ça
reste diffus enfin je veux dire voilà
c'est ça moins de grève aujourd'hui pour
les conservateurs que ça ne les
inciterait à aller aux élections
absolument aucun intérêt et je vois pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi dans ce dans il le
ferait en fait juste d'un g si j'ose
dire là la chose sur le plan politique
de les conservateurs n'ont absolument
pas prises en compte c'est que
l'électorat conservateur a bougé c'est à
dire qu'il est constitué aujourd'hui
d'une partie d'exélecteurs travaillent
notamment aborigène et oui voilà le mur
rouge exactement et donc un certain
nombre d'électeurs qui ne sont pas pour
l'absence totale de l'État par exemple
dans la régulation et qui ont font ont
importé dans leur vote conservateur un
certain nombre de caractéristiques
travaillistes et ça les taulues actuels
ne l'ont pas vu du tout et c'est pour ça
qu'ils se retrouvent aussi si mal dans
les dans les prévisions et un dernier
mot le retour de Boris Johnson n'est pas
ce qui revient d'ailleurs nous dit-on
enfin c'est le télégra qui nous le dit
par avion un débat Hamas où il se
reposait visiblement tranquillement donc
alors là ce serait vraiment le comble
mais ce serait la suite du conte de fées
au sens voilà bon il faut dire que
l'Europe elle-même d'ailleurs a commencé
à montrer de sérieux signe de division
par où commencer à commencer à parce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler son moteur le
fameux couple franco-allemand le Conseil
des minisbi national prévu la semaine
prochaine au château de Fontainebleau
près de Paris et reporté en toile de
fond il y avait déjà le plan de soutien
à l'industriellement dégainé de manière
unilatérale par Berlin et dont le
montant 200 milliards d'euros et jugé
disproportionné par ses partenaires au
point d'être assimilé une forme de
concurrence déloyale et il n'y a pas que
ça un plafonnement du prix du gaz sur
lequel les deux pays s'entendent pas
projet de bouclier aérien pour l'Europe
sans la France écouter manuel Macron
s'exprimer sur la question de ses
relations avec l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui quand même une très large
unité entre les pays donc je vais
travailler avec trop que chancelier je
pense que ce n'est pas bon ni pour
l'Allemagne ni pour l'Europe quel
s'isole et donc il est important que sur
une des propositions qui font l'objet
d'un assez large consensus on puisse
trouver une unanimité voilà Emmanuel
Macron a Bruxelles tout comme d'ailleurs
pour un conseiller européen ou le qui se
déroule en ce moment les contentieux
s'accumulent de quand même dans un temps
très court beaucoup de causes de tension
en Europe en tout cas entre le moteur
franco-allemand à un moment où on le
sait on est aussi face à l'Ukraine face
à la guerre en Ukraine et donc face à la
Russie et donc on aurait plutôt tendance
à se dire c'est le moment d'être uni
mais mon Poutine a quand même un petit
peu réussissant coup il faut l'avouer
puisque
ces histoires de gaz a mis l'Allemagne
dans une telle situation que finalement
des contentieux historiques puisque
c'est un contentieux historique la
question de l'énergie entre la femme la
France et l'Allemagne qui était un peu
cachée sous le reste mais la France
historiquement c'est le nucléaire tandis
l'Allemagne c'est les écologistes l'anti
nucléaire les énergies renouvelables le
gaz voilà et puis aussi les centrales à
charbon etc pas que de l'écologie bien
sûr mais en tout cas une autre vision et
puis il y a des questions plus de fond
pareil vous parliez de l'achat des F35
américains je crois du bouclier
anti-missiles ça c'est aussi une
idéologie ancienne qui est différente
entre la France et l'Allemagne puisque
la France l'a toujours voulu pousser
pour une Europe de la défense là où
l'Allemagne comptait plutôt sur l'OTAN
et un certain atlantisme donc en fait il
y a toutes ces questions de fond qui
étaient cachées un peu pendant des
années parce qu'il y avait Angela Merkel
il y avait cette entente ce réflexe très
Franco francofils finalement de
l'Allemagne et pareil de la France que
là cette façon de faire cavalier seul de
l'Allemagne réveille un peu tous ces
tous ses contentieux oubliés la faute à
qui Gautier fait-il un peu trop cavalier
seul aujourd'hui à une période en plus
ou bien sûr ça fait les affaires de la
Russie oui
à vrai dire j'ai pas de religion très
précise sur la question je crois qu'on
raciste mais c'est un infirmant rien ce
que disent à madame je crois qu'on
assiste à la naissance à la venue au
monde d'une Allemagne politique qui n'a
jusqu'à présent été qu'une Allemagne
économique qui était comme nous on le
disait un nain politique et ça
l'arrangeait aussi parce qu'elle se
livrait à finalement à un commerce qui
lui était bénéfique avec des excédents
très conséquents et que elle n'avait pas
à prendre des responsabilités dans
finalement dans les affaires du monde et
aujourd'hui on a bien vu quand l'espace
de quelques mois on est revenu sur
l'idée de l'arme des ventes d'armes les
chars léopards ou guépard ça semble être
en voie de ce de se régler
y compris sur le nucléaire vous avez
aujourd'hui par exemple
robertabek qui est le qui est le
ministre des Finances qui est un qui est
un écologiste et qui commence à se dire
peut-être qu'à titre transitoire on
pourrait revenir au nucléaire donc je
veux dire que cette Allemagne elle est
en presque en exempuino permanente on
elle change de référence alors est-ce
qu'il y a un cavalier seul bon il y a il
y a un réflexe classique en Allemagne
c'est de faire en sorte que on défende à
tout prix les entreprises et surtout le
tissu très connu des petits et moyens
d'entreprises qui font la force et la
rentabilité de l'Allemagne et que donc à
partir de là si on a ça on aura un pays
qui sera qui souffrira le moins possible
de cette crise nous les 200 milliards
sont concertation oui sans concertation
c'est ça c'est ça le problème mais d'une
autre manière vous avez par exemple
Macron qui dit cette histoire de de ne
pas vouloir un plafonnement du Gabri du
gaz c'est tout simplement une manière
d'être de ne pas se solidariser alors
que ce que dit Scholtz c'est qu'il dit
que au fond un plafonnement prix du gaz
ça risque par ricochet de le rendre
encore plus cher et donc d'avoir une
spirituelle toujours l'argument de
l'efficacité côté allemand par
opposition à ce que les Français voient
comme une forme de morale finalement oui
mais les Français aussi pour les
Allemands les Français les toutes les
aides que les Français accordent des
vers
elle est d'une certaine manière
errante aujourd'hui mais ça n'est pas
que les
inefficacité ou l'efficacité qui joue
dans en un mot une réponse chacun très
brève on l'a vu Royaume-Uni sans Premier
ministre ce soir coupe franco-allemand
qui bat de l'aile Poutine à quoi jubilé
c'est pas une mauvaise période pour
Vladimir Poutine même si bon quoi c'est
quand même sur le terrain il y a encore
des pertes oui parce qu'il dit quand
même que la livraison massive d'armes à
l'Ukraine et quelque chose qui relève
pas tout à fait la cobelligérance il a
dit pas comme ça mais ça l'inquiète plus
que ça merci merci Gauthier merci Madame
Mustaf avis c'était ton vois plus loin
on se retrouve dans un peu plus de 3
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous
[Musique]